mein Name ist goldene atai ich bin eine
deutsche Journalistin ZDF
Auslandskorrespondentin geboren in Tera
die Welt schaut nach Katar und ich reise
die arabische Halbinsel eine Region
volle Widersprüche
[Musik]
meine Reise führt mich nach Oman er
Saudi-Arabien Kuweit und Dubai und ich
frage mich in welchem Spannungsfeld
leben die Menschen hier in autoritären
Staaten aber wirtschaftlich sorgenfrei
es hat mich geschockt wie viel
Möglichkeiten ich habe wo ich Mutter
sein darf und trotzdem gut Geld
verdienen kann
Länder reich an Ressourcen und vor
Selbstbewusstsein strotzend
und ihr werdet aus einer Abhängigkeit in
die nächste Abhängigkeit geraten
welche Rolle spielt Religion
wie frei seid ihr drei mit gewissen
Einschränkungen alles basiert auf
Religion und Kultur
aber ich breche die Regeln
was fordern junge Menschen erleben wir
auch in der Golfregion einen
demokratischen Aufbruch einen Kampf um
mehrpolitische Mitbestimmung dort Happen
was gerade geschieht ist eine echte
Revolution
[Musik]
ein wenig erinnert mich die Landschaft
an die grünen Hügel Schottlands aber ich
befinde mich im Süden Omans am Fuße des
davor Gebirges
[Musik]
hier beginne ich meine Reise in Salalah
nahe der Grenze zum Jemen
[Musik]
dort wo einmal im Jahr mitten in der
Wüste ein Wunder geschieht von Juni bis
September wenn der südwestmonsum an die
Berghänge prallt ist Regenzeit der
sogenannte Tarif verwandelt die sonst zu
carge Landschaft in einer Art Karibik
des Orients und hunderttausende
vorwiegende arabische Touristen kommen
und genießen den Nieselregen ich treffe
Ali und seine Frau Marion sie sind aus
dem heißen Muskat angereist ihre beiden
Töchter sind bei den Großeltern ich
möchte von Ihnen wissen was junge
Familien im Oman bewegt und wie ihr
Alltag aussieht
für uns als Europäer sind Regen und
grüne Landschaften nichts besonderes
aber für euch ist es wirklich besonders
gut
im ganzen Jahr vielleicht zwei drei Mal
deswegen entspannt uns der Regen und
diese schöne grüne Landschaft
wir sind alle unter Druck im Alltag hier
können wir uns seelisch entspannen
was bewegt euch denn als junge
Generation als junge Familie
wir junge Leute brauchen momentan viel
Geduld
seit Corona ist alles schwieriger
geworden
und Unterstützung von anderen
[Musik]
lange gehörte Oman zu den reichsten
Ländern der Welt dank seiner Öle und
Gasvorräte doch die Auswirkungen der
corona-pandemie haben zeitweise zu einer
Rezession geführt und besonders die
Jugendarbeitslosigkeit steigt
nach jahrzehntelangem ungebremsten
Wachstum müssen sich junge Omanis
erstmals neuen Herausforderungen stellen
um das Land zu verändern
neue Generation kann das Land
weiterentwickeln
die Denkweise der alten Generation ist
überholt
wir sind im Jahr 2022
deren Zeit ist einfach vorbei
Oman will es endlich an die Spitze
schaffen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
hier im vadidar Wald fällt mir das
entspannte Miteinander zwischen
arabische Tradition und moderner
Lebensart besonders ins Auge für
niemanden erscheint das als Widerspruch
und das obwohl der Süden als
traditionell und konservativ gilt
die hiesige dafar-region ist die Wiege
des Weihrauchs überall liegt der Duft
des Orients in der Luft das lockt mich
auf den einzigen weihrauchbasar der Welt
hier in Salalah komme ich mit einer
jungen Verkäuferin ins Gespräch Mariam
trägt einen Gesichtsschleier wie so
viele hier obwohl er nicht
vorgeschrieben ist wie traditionell ist
der Alltag will ich von der 21-Jährigen
erfahren
das ist gut für Körper und Haare und für
das Gesicht das macht deine Haare schön
und die Haut
ein Familienunternehmen oder dein
Geschäft
es gehört meiner Mutter die hat auch das
hier alles selbst hergestellt wird das
denn Hauptjob bleiben
vielleicht
es gefällt mir mit den Menschen ins
Gespräch zu kommen aus allen möglichen
Ländern die unterschiedlichste Sprachen
sprechen das mag ich an diesem Shop
sag mir was willst du unbedingt in
deinem Leben erreichen
ich möchte Weihrauch bekannter machen in
anderen Ländern erreichen dass Menschen
mehr über Weihrauch Wissen wünschst du
dir auch einen Ehemann Kinder und so
weiter
das ist nicht meine Idealvorstellung
erstmal möchte ich Geschäftsfrau sein
und dann sich weiter okay
ich erlebe eine weltoffene und
aufgeschlossene junge Frau die in ihrer
Haltung so gar nicht manchem westlichen
Klischee entspricht mit ihrem
Geschäftspartner Ahmad fahre ich ins
Herz des weihrauchlands seine Familie
handelt schon seit Jahrhunderten mit dem
kostbaren Harz
die Bäume gelten als Gabe Gottes weil
man sie weder züchten noch verpflanzen
kann sie wachsen nur an ganz bestimmten
Standorten die Bäume gehören
verschiedenen Clans und des ernterecht
wird an die männlichen Nachkommen
vererbt ahme zeigt mir wie man den
Weihrauch erntet
ich werde mit dem Messer die erste
Schicht vom Baum entfernen das ist der
erste Schritt
zunächst entferne ich diese dünne
Schicht vom Baum dann produziert der
Baum eine herzige Substanz die später zu
Weihrauch wird
es riecht wundervoll
es riecht wirklich wie Parfüm
unglaublich
nach zwei bis drei Wochen wird die
Kruste entfernt und der Weihrauch kann
geerntet werden
ein Baum produziert während der Saison
zwischen vier und acht Kilogramm
Weihrauch das hängt von der Stärke dem
Standort und der Größe des Baumes ab
Ahmad will mir noch mehr über die
omanische Mischung aus ursprünglicher
und moderner Lebensart zeigen wir machen
uns auf den Weg zum Jahrmarkt in Salalah
doch unterwegs müssen wir anhalten er
möchte beten wegen unserer Dreharbeiten
hat er schon drei Gebetszeiten ausfallen
lassen
einmal im Jahr ist Jahrmarkt in Salalah
zum Tarif und alle feiern Denise reden
Alkohol ist verboten wie im ganzen Land
ansonsten mutet die Stimmung hier
ziemlich ähnlich an wie in Europa
[Musik]
Ahmad ist sehr stolz auf seine Heimat
und die Traditionen Salalah ist auch für
seine
kamelfleisch-spezialitäten vom Grill
berühmt
er führt mich direkt in die Küche
auf Kieselstein
[Musik]
hier gibt es Hähnchenfleisch und
Ziegenfleisch
das ist eine traditionelle Methode die
die Restaurants nutzen um die
Besonderheit der Stadt zu fahren
[Musik]
vom weihrauchhandel allein kann die
Familie nicht leben deshalb arbeitet
Ahmed als Beamter im Umweltministerium
wie denkt er über die wirtschaftlichen
Herausforderungen vor denen sein Land
steht was wünscht er sich für die
Zukunft seine Kinder
welche Ausbildung sollen deine Kinder
erhalten du hast ja drei Töchter oder ja
das stimmt
in unsere Generation hat sich alles
entwickelt für die alte Generation war
das viel schwieriger es gab kaum
Ausbildungsmöglichkeiten wir legen jetzt
sehr viel Wert darauf dass unsere Kinder
egal ob Junge oder Mädchen eine gute
Ausbildung bekommen dass sie sich immer
weiter verbessern und das höchstmögliche
Niveau erreichen also dass sie studieren
oder sogar einen Doktortitel erhalten
das höchste was man erreichen kann
Bildung für junge Frauen das ist für
viele Omanis eine Selbstverständlichkeit
schließe ich aus ahmads Erzählungen auch
hier im vermeintlich konservativen Süden
woran liegt es frage ich mich und Reise
weiter nach Muscat in die Hauptstadt
als einer der wenigen Herrscher im
Mittleren Osten setzte sich der 2020
verstorbene Schultern Rabus für die
Förderung von Frauen und ihre Bildung
ein
der Oman ist ein ganz besonderes Land
das viele auch als die Schweiz der
arabischen Welt bezeichnen wegen seiner
Neutralität und den guten Beziehungen zu
allen regionalmächten es gibt hier weder
Glaubens noch Bürgerkriege und das
scheint vor allem an der Religion zu
liegen dem ibanismus eine kleine eher
liberale Strömung im Islam in der großen
Moschee von Muskat wird
überkonfessionell gebetet
[Musik]
was immer die Muslime sonst trennt
spielt hier keine Rolle alle beten
zusammen eine Besonderheit
der Minister für religiöse Beziehungen
mohammed almai hat mich zu sich nach
Hause eingeladen ich möchte von ihm
wissen warum die Religion hier
verbindende wirkt als anderswo und
vereint statt zu entzweihen was sind die
wesentlichen Werte des überdosismus war
die Werte unserer Konfession sind die
Ablehnung von Gewalt Extremismus und
Hass reden
Toleranz und Koexistenz nicht nur
zwischen Muslimen sondern zwischen allen
Religionen Kulturen und Zivilisation
wie wichtig ist die Religion für die
junge Generation
ist ein Glaube der sowohl den Verstand
als auch die Moral prägt
sich an die Zeit in der wir leben
anpassen da gibt es keinen Widerspruch
auch junge Leute sehen da keinen
Widerspruch zwischen Religion und
modernem Leben
und in Oman gesellschaftlich tiefer
ankert vielmehr als die Kirche bei uns
scheint mir
das spüre ich auch beim Besuch der
German University of Technology der
einzigen deutschen Uni auf der
arabischen Halbinsel Oman ist ein sehr
junges Land der altes Durchschnitt liegt
bei 28 Jahren ein Großteil der jungen
Menschen studiert Männer wie Frauen was
wäre das Leben ohne Religion warum lebst
du überhaupt wenn du nicht religiös bist
ich glaube die Geologie ist tief
verbunden mit dem Sinn des Lebens das
ist das wichtigste und der Hauptgrund
warum ich mich für Geologie entschieden
habe
hier ist eine Hülse wahrscheinlich von
einer Muschel oder etwas anderem schaust
dir mal an
der Geologe Wilfried Bauer lebt und
lehrt seit gut sieben Jahren in moskat
mich interessiert wie er den Oman und
seine Studentinnen und Studenten erlebt
es ist ein Land in dem Autoritäten und
bestimmte Prozesse nicht in Frage
gestellt werden das ist ganz anders als
in Deutschland wo man sehr kritisch ist
auch den Professoren gegenüber und ich
kann nicht bei jungen Generationen sehen
dass die jetzt nach politischer
Veränderung strebt wirtschaftliches
Wohlergehen steht bei denen dann erster
Stelle was muss im Land passieren auf
die nächsten Jahrzehnte hin betrachtet
letztendlich wird es darauf ankommen in
der jungen Generation das entsprechende
human-kapital heranzubilden jetzt müssen
aber auch die jungen Leute selbst dran
sie müssen mit anpacken neue Ideen neue
Konzepte entwickeln und das schein bei
mir noch nicht bei allen angekommen zu
sein viele verlassen sich halt darauf
nach dem Abschluss dass die Regierung
dafür sorgen wird dass sie irgendwo eine
Stelle bekommen
hauda und Malak studieren beide
Stadtplanung und erhoffen sich so gute
Jobaussichten mit Ihnen spreche ich auch
über die Rolle von Frauen mir fällt auf
dass viele Frauen Schleier tragen obwohl
es hier offiziell keine Verpflichtung
gibt
wie frei seid ihr ich meine es gibt
Normen ungeschriebene Gesetze
natürlich gibt es gesellschaftlichen
Druck aber es kommt auch auf deinen
Glauben an also wenn es um die Religion
geht ich bin Muslimin nicht weil meine
Eltern Muslime sind sondern weil ich an
diese Dinge Glaube und genauso mache ich
bestimmte Dinge nicht weil mich die
Gesellschaft einschränkt sondern weil
ich mir selbst bestimmte Grenzen
auferlege also es gibt rote Linien die
ich nicht überschreiten möchte aber das
ist so weil ich daran glaube
und wenn es um die Beziehung zu einem
Mann geht darfst du damit bestimmen
ich würde nicht nur um meiner Familie
Willen ja sagen wenn ich wirklich
dagegen wäre aber ich würde auch Ihre
Wünsche respektieren ich habe das Gefühl
dass es immer möglich ist ein Mittelweg
zu finden so dass beide Seiten glücklich
sind ich finde nicht dass arrangierte
ihn unbedingt schlecht sind
manchmal ist man ja auch nicht wirklich
daran interessiert Menschen über die Uni
oder die Arbeit kennenzulernen und wenn
sie dann jemanden über die Familie
kennenlernen funktioniert das gut also
ich finde es ist nicht so schlecht wie
sich viele Menschen das vielleicht
vorstellen
an der staatlichen Uni gibt es
inzwischen eine Männerquote weil junge
Frauen in der Überzahl sind in der
gesamten Golfregion ergreifen viele
Frauen technische und wissenschaftliche
Berufe anders als bei uns gelten die
nicht als männerdomenen ein Drittel der
Frauen im Oman ist berufstätig kommst
ich glaube am Ende hat man die Wahl in
unserer Kultur ist es so dass wenn eine
Frau nicht arbeiten möchte ist dass ihre
Entscheidung weil sie ja die Kinder
erzieht aber sie muss nicht zu Hause
bleiben sie kann sich entscheiden
Hausfrau zu sein aber es gibt sehr viele
Frauen hier die einen Vollzeitjob haben
und sich um den Haushalt kümmern das ist
etwas ganz Normales
future Job was eure Aussichten auf einen
Job angeht könnte das schwierig werden
[Musik]
die Herausforderung ist natürlich das
Oman gerade in einer Rezession steckt
die Arbeitslosigkeit steigt dramatisch
damit müssen sich alle umamis
auseinandersetzen Männer und Frauen
natürlich ist das ärgerlich aber
gleichzeitig hat uns das auch neue
Möglichkeiten eröffnet vor allem für uns
junge Menschen sie müssen sich auf sich
selbst verlassen und auf einmal öffnen
überall neue Firmen also ja natürlich
ist das ein Rückschlag aber gleichzeitig
auch eine Gelegenheit für die Jugend
im Mai 2021 verbreiten sich über die
soziale Netzwerke für das Land
ungewohnte Bilder
in mehreren Städten kommt es zu
Protesten junge Menschen tragen ihren
Unmut auf die Straße ihnen geht es aber
nicht um politische Freiheiten oder
demokratischen Aufbruch ihr Unmut
richtet sich gegen die vom Sultan
verordneten Sparmaßnahmen
denn der neue Sultan Sultan haifam fährt
einen strikten Reformkurs er hat
staatliche Finanzhilfen reduziert und
eine Mehrwertsteuer eingeführt
omanswirtschaft muss sich neu erfinden
loskommen von den endlichen Ressourcen
werden diese wirtschaftlichen
Herausforderungen am Ende den Wunsch
nach größerer politischer Mitbestimmung
hervorrufen
noch hat die Freiheit auch in dem für
die Region vergleichsweise Liberalen
Oman ihre Grenzen des landrangiert auf
Platz 163 wenn es schon die
Pressefreiheit geht
homosexualität ist verboten Kritik an
der Regierung oder dem Königshaus Tabu
ich treffe Haifa laut Forbes Magazine
eine der wichtigsten Frauen im mittleren
Osten sie ist Chefin der Energy
development Oman einem staatlichen
Energiekonzern sie soll die Energiewende
und damit die wirtschaftliche
Neuausrichtung vorantreiben
die Grünen Sektoren sind neu in Oman
also naturbasierte Lösungen wie ccis
Wasserstoff erneuerbare Energien
einschließlich Solarkraft und Wind
und diese neuen grünen Sektoren sollen
jetzt das Einkommen verbessern das
bislang eben vollkommen abhängig war von
Öl und
ihre Karriere ist sehr beeindruckend
wie war das für sie als junge Frau in
einer Männerdomäne tätig zu werden sich
zu trauen da reinzugehen
ja sie haben rechtes handelt sich um
eine männerdominierte Industrie aber in
Oman haben wir glücklicherweise ein
Gleichstellungsgesetz und es gibt viele
Möglichkeiten für Frauen in technischen
Bereichen ich glaube das liegt daran
dass unsere Wirtschaft so sehr von
diesen technischen Fähigkeiten abhängt
dass sich auch deshalb viele Frauen für
diese Bereiche interessieren
welche Ziele müssen wir uns dennoch
setzen um Gleichberechtigung zu
erreichen
Diversität und Inklusion stehen ganz
oben auf der Agenda unserer Regierung
ich glaube es handelt sich auch wirklich
sich um ein globales Thema das wir
angehen müssen ich bin mir nicht sicher
warum wir als Frauen einander nicht mehr
stärken und unterstützen Männer sind
besser darin das ist nicht Sache der
Regierung ich glaube das ist wirklich
etwas das Frauen selbst für sich ändern
müssen
ob sie damit Recht hat dass es Sache der
Frauen selbst ist in einem Land des von
patriarchalen Strukturen geprägt ist ist
das für mich ein streitbarer Standpunkt
den wir aber auch aus Debatten in
Deutschland kennen am frühen Abend eine
Zufallsbekanntschaft am Strand Mariam
macht sich gerade mit einem kleinen
Smoothie Business selbstständig für die
neue Webseite braucht sie noch
Werbefotos
wovon träumt sie Erfolg im Beruf mehr
persönliche Unabhängigkeit mehr
politische Freiheiten
als Frau spüren sie da irgendwelche
Grenzen oder steht die Welt ihnen
offensichtlich überall Grenzen aber ich
habe die Regeln schon immer gebrochen
sogar um außer Landes zu reisen ich
halte mich nicht an die Regeln ich habe
mein eigenes Business und darum muss ich
reisen also mache ich das einfach
außerdem gehört sich für ein Mädchen
nicht jeder Job naja und wenn man anders
ist schauen einen alle an und reden
darüber warum sie das machen und so
und wie reagieren ihre Eltern wenn sie
Regeln brechen
also mein Vater hat in den USA studiert
und ist ziemlich offen und das ist okay
für ihn aber meine Mutter sagt ab und zu
dass ich etwas nicht machen kann aber
dann erkläre ich ihr meine Gründe und
dass ich das sehr wohl tun kann warum
auch nicht das ist doch ganz einfach
alles ist heute einfach easy er bringt
genau
und würden Sie lieber auswandern oder
lieber hier bleiben
ja ich möchte gerne auswandern ich bin
verlobt und sage meinem Verlobten
täglich dass wir das Land verlassen
sollten woanders einen Job finden wir
sind beide Buchhalter es wäre überhaupt
kein Problem woanders einen Job zu
finden
[Musik]
was müsste sich hier verändern damit sie
bleiben
sehr viel sie müssen das Verkehrssystem
ändern mehr Jobs anbieten sie müssen
mehrmals öffnen viele Sachen viele
Sachen gibt es hier nicht wir fahren
darum ständig woanders hin zumindest
nach Dubai
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
mein Eindruck ist viele junge Frauen
wollen unabhängig sein sind dabei aber
weitgehend unpolitisch und streben vor
allem nach wirtschaftlichen Erfolg in
einem Land das geprägt ist von
Jahrtausende alten Traditionen und
gleichzeitig aufgeschlossen und modern
[Musik]
ich verlasse den Oman Richtung
Saudi-Arabien dem gefürchteten und
mächtigsten Player der Region ich möchte
wissen ob junge Menschen im Königreich
zu einer treibenden Kraft werden könnten
für einen demokratischen Aufbruch und
Reise nach Twitter am Roten Meer
lange schien sich das konservativ
islamische Königreich Saudi-Arabien
abschirmen zu wollen vom Rest der Welt
doch seit 2017 hat Kronprinz Mohammad
Wind Salman dem Land einen radikalen
Modernisierungskurs verordnet die
33-Jährige Tanja Kiel chauffiert mich
durch den dichten Verkehr von jeder zu
den liberalisierungsmaßnahmen des
Kronprinzen gehört auch dass Frauen seit
vier Jahren endlich ihren Führerschein
machen und Autofahren dürfen
beschreibe den Moment in dem Du hier am
Lenkrad sitzen und fahren durftest
das war ein gutes Gefühl ehrlich gesagt
dachte ich vorher nicht dass es einen
großen Unterschied für mich machen würde
weil ich mich auch noch nie so richtig
eingeschränkt gefühlt hatte als wir noch
nicht fahren durften ich konnte immer
auf ein Fahrzeug zurückgreifen dass mich
überall hingebracht hat auch wenn ich
nicht selbst am Steuer sitzen durfte
aber ich habe das wirklich unterschätzt
dieses unglaubliche Freiheitsgefühl dass
mich überkam als ich dann endlich am
Steuer saß das ist etwas vollkommen
anderes als gefahren zu werden ganz
anders als ich es erwartet hatte
dann waren die ersten Minuten so richtig
toll
sie waren fantastisch aber noch besser
hat sich wahrscheinlich meine Mutter
gefühlt und Frauen ihre Generation ich
konnte so etwa zehn Jahre lang nicht
fahren als ich in meinen 20ern war aber
bei meiner Mutter waren es die 20er 30er
40er also bin ich mir sicher ihre
Glücksgefühle waren tausendmal stärker
noch als meine ich freue mich wirklich
für sie und die anderen
der Stadtverkehr geht es reichte Daniel
nicht nur ein Jahr nach Aufhebung
Fahrverbots hielt sie ihre
Wettkampflizenz daniel ist eine
Pionierin sie war die erste Frau aus
Saudi-Arabien die eine internationale
Rallye-Meisterschaft gewann und die
erste die bei der berühmt berüchtigten
Rally da kam
wie war es an der Rally DAK teilzunehmen
an diesem spektakulären Rennen
es hat sehr viel Spaß gemacht da waren
so viele spannende Elemente dabei ich
habe es wirklich geliebt ich bin am Ende
unter die ersten Zehn gefahren als
erster Saudi überhaupt und das war eine
unglaubliche Erfahrung
ich begleite Daniel zu ihrem täglichen
Training in einem gemischten
Fitnessstudio auch das vor fünf Jahren
unmöglich
die öffnungsschritte sind Teil der
sogenannten Vision 2030 mit der der
Kronprinz des Land umstrukturieren will
vom ölabhängigen
ultrakonservativen rentierstört zum
innovativen weltmarkt-player mit
blühende Privatwirtschaft dafür braucht
der Kronprinz die Frauen und gewährt
Ihnen deshalb neue Möglichkeiten
[Musik]
wie inspirierst du andere Frauen
dasselbe zu erreichen
naja eigentlich hoffe ich Menschen zu
inspirieren dass sie verstehen dass sie
eine Wahl haben was sie machen wollen
heute haben wir viel mehr Möglichkeiten
als früher man kann sich aussuchen was
man machen möchte ich möchte jetzt nicht
allen vorschlagen dass sie Rennfahrerin
werden sollten oder so mir geht es mehr
darum zu vermitteln dass man eine Wahl
hat und aktiv werden kann wobei auch
immer
[Gelächter]
daniel hat in England BWL studiert
später als Unternehmensberaterin
gearbeitet
die hast du dich je eingeschränkt
gefühlt als Frau
es gibt in jeder Gesellschaft soziale
Namen und seit jeher haben Frauen Kinder
und erziehen sie
das ist überall so nicht nur in
Saudi-Arabien
ich finde ohnehin dass es auf der Welt
viel mehr Ähnlichkeiten zwischen Frauen
gibt als Unterschiede
wie blickst du in die Zukunft
wenn du mich als Individuum fragst dann
wünsche ich mir auf jeden Fall Familie
und dass ich eines Tages Mutter sein
kann wenn möglich und ich würde gerne
meine Karriere weiterentwickeln ich weiß
nicht wir werden sehen was geschieht
[Gelächter]
für seine Reformpolitik lässt sich der
Kronprinz gerne feiern wie hier beim
Nationalfeiertag Mohammed bin Salman
inszeniert sich als junger Modernisierer
Kinos sind wieder geöffnet Konzerte
dürfen stattfinden und die strikte
Geschlechtertrennung ist aufgehoben so
will er vor allem junge Saudis für sich
einnehmen auch wenn viele seiner
Positionen nicht verhandelbar sind wie
meinungs- oder Pressefreiheit die
Todesstrafe für Homosexualität oder den
Übertritt zum Christentum
preisgekrönter Journalist weiß genau wo
sich die roten Linien befinden er hat
jahrzehntelang für mehr Freiheit
gekämpft
ich glaube es gibt jetzt Hoffnung da ist
ein Licht am Ende des Tunnels für die
Millionen junger Menschen die vorher
nicht Teil eines Plans waren und jetzt
in verschiedenen wichtigen Projekten im
Königreich partizipieren ich rede nicht
über irgendwelche kosmetischen Maßnahmen
wie viele westliche Medien das Frauen
jetzt Autofahren dürfen und so das hätte
ja alles schon vor langer Zeit passieren
müssen aber was jetzt gerade passiert
ist meiner Meinung nach eine echte
Revolution
aber es gibt doch konservative Kräfte in
der Gesellschaft die mit diesem
Modernisierungsprozess nicht glücklich
sind wer sind die
das sind die Menschen die jahrelang die
Gesellschaft beherrscht haben also das
sogenannte religiöse ist typisch Mensch
aber die können nie wieder zurückkehren
denn jetzt haben die Menschen soziale
Freiheit kennengelernt Menschen haben
das Gefühl tun zu dürfen was sie wollen
wir wollen Fortschritt wir wollen uns
auf die Modernisierung konzentrieren
aber wir wollen keine Kopie des Westens
werden das ist der Schlüssel
[Musik]
wir wollen keine Kopie des Westens
werden das höre ich immer wieder das
Geld anscheinend aber nicht für die neu
entstandene Entertainmentindustrie die
der Staat jetzt fördert Unterhaltung für
junge Saudis auch um so neue Jobs zu
schaffen
[Musik]
ein Rockkonzert vor gemischtem Publikum
vor fünf Jahren wäre das schlicht
unmöglich gewesen so weit geht der
Wandel ein Wunder erzählt mir Sänger
Abdel Malik der als Englischlehrer
arbeitet
er singt über seine Gefühle und das in
englischer Sprache noch vor kurzem ein
weiteres absolutes No-Go
woher nimmst du deine Inspiration
to me music
die Musik ist für mich ein Ventil über
das ich meine Frustration loswerden kann
die meisten unserer Lieder beschäftigen
sich mit Schwächen mit Dingen die uns
reizen oder frustrieren aber
[Musik]
rote Linien für eure Texte
eigentlich alles was Menschen irgendwie
beleidigen könnte
da gibt es vieles Politik kann Menschen
beleidigen Ideologie
ich meine wir leben in einem Land in
einer Gesellschaft in der wir sehr genau
wissen wo unsere Grenzen sind darum
wissen wir auch als Individuen genau
worüber wir reden können und worüber
nicht aber es gibt jetzt keine
speziellen Behörden oder Menschen die
sich uns in den Weg stellen
[Musik]
die strengen Regeln sind tief verwurzelt
vor allem wenn es um gesellschaftliche
Vorstellungen von Moral und
individueller Freiheit geht
wird es zu einer zereisprobe kommen für
die saudische Gesellschaft
[Musik]
wie reagiert denn die Gesellschaft auf
euch
ich glaube für die neue Generation ist
das einfach Teil ihrer Denkweise und es
gehört einfach schon zu Ihnen diese
ganzen Veränderungen zu akzeptieren und
sie umarmen sie von ganzem Herzen die
ältere Generation wurde dagegen seit
ihrer Kindheit von sehr fixen Ideen
geprägt
wir sprechen hier über einen Turm der
über viele Jahre erbaut wurde
wir sind jetzt so let me Beat
so you can't ne den kann man auch nicht
einfach abreißen und am selben Tag
wieder aufbauen
das ist ein langer Prozess und das
braucht seine Zeit aber am Ende werden
wir alle auf demselben Stand sein glaube
ich
[Musik]
[Applaus]
mit seine Vision 2030 will der Kronprinz
des Land in die Zukunft weisen die
Kehrseite der modernisierungsmedaille in
Gitter werden ganze Wohnviertel dem
Erdboden gleich gemacht mehrere
hunderttausend Menschen vertrieben das
können wir nur aus dem Auto Filmen denn
solche Bilder sind unerwünscht
[Musik]
seinem öffnungskurs zum Trotz der
Kronprinz und Premierminister verfolgt
einen absolutistischen Machtanspruch
Kritik ist tabu und kann tödlich sein
traurige Berühmtheit erlangte 2018 der
Mord an dem Journalisten Jamaika in dem
der Kronprinz als Auftraggeber gilt
[Musik]
über Menschenrechtsverletzungen spreche
ich noch einmal mit Halle del Marina der
als früherer Chefredakteur von Eric News
lange mit Jamaika schurki
zusammenarbeitete
wir beobachten im Moment mehr
Menschenrechtsverletzungen von Seiten
des Staats warum passiert es
ich habe darauf keine Antwort ich werde
ehrlich sein ich habe das Gefühl dass
die Dinge richtig gestellt werden ich
bin Optimist ich schaue mir vor allem
die positiven Seiten an und ich bin mir
sicher der Kronprinz wird Reifen er hat
die Interessen unseres Landes im Blick
und wird viele Dinge langfristig
zurücksetzen ich möchte weder
verteidigen noch angreifen aber ich muss
Ihnen sagen dass die positiven Dinge mir
wie eine Lawine vorkommen
es gibt Dinge die angegangen werden
müssen ich bin nicht eingeweiht was
hinter den Kulissen vor sich geht aber
ich bin mir sicher dass viele Dinge noch
zurück gesetzt werden
doch einige Organisationen sprechen von
einer Zuspitzung
2022 erreichte Saudi-Arabien einen
traurigen Rekord mit 81 Hinrichtungen an
einem einzigen Tag Freiheit ist nach wie
vor kein Recht der Bürger sondern ein
Privileg dass der Staat gewährt das
zeigt doch der Fall von lucaine alhat
loud sie hatte es Fahrrecht für Frauen
eingefordert was der Kronprinz wenig
später auch zugestand doch lucaine wurde
zu fünf Jahren und 8 Monaten Haft
verurteilt ein Interview mit mir wäre
für sie lebensgefährlich ihre Schwester
Lina lebt in Europa und beschreibt was
Lucian ihr über die Haft erzählt hat
meine Schwester wurde brutal gefoltert
sie wurde mit Stromschlägen gequält
Waterboarding sie wurde ausgepeitscht
und sexuell belästigt von Männern auch
von der rechten Hand des Kronprinzen
sein Name ist sahut alcatani er war auch
in den Mord an dem Journalisten Jamaika
Schoggi involviert
sie wurde dann fast ein Jahr später zu
fünf Jahren und acht Monaten Haft
verurteilt und jetzt hat sie ein
Reiseverbot
wie beispielhaft ist die Geschichte
ihrer Schwester für die aktuelle Lage in
Saudi-Arabien
der Fall meiner Schwester ist sehr
symbolisch ich glaube er sagt sehr viel
darüber aus was im Land los ist
nach der Entlassung von Lou Jane dachten
viele die Situation würde sich jetzt
verbessern weil sie ja diejenige war die
alles symbolisierte also den Aktivismus
genau wie die Unterdrückung aber das ist
nicht der Fall
Entlassung wurden weitere
Frauenrechtlerinnen verhaftet wie Lina
Sharif oder Adina abdelassis die auch
nur getweetet haben
Sie das Gefühl dass die Spannungen
aktuell steigen
das Regime nutzt das was im Westen sexy
klingt um so zu verdecken was im Land
geschieht der Westen möchte gerne hören
dass Frauen jetzt frei sind dass sie
Konzerte besuchen dürfen dass sie mehr
Freiheiten haben aber in der Realität
hat sich die Situation nicht verbessert
weder im Hinblick auf Frauenrechte noch
auf Menschenrecht im allgemeinen wir
sind in einer sehr schwarzen düsteren
Ära in Saudi-Arabien wenn es um
Menschenrechte und Frauenrechte geht ja
es hat Veränderung gegeben aber das
bedeutet nicht dass es sich um Reformen
handelt
nach der Ermordung von Jamaika Schoggi
war der Kronprinz zumindest kurzzeitig
international geächtet doch die Folgen
des ukraine-krieges haben ihn erneut zu
einem im Westen begehrten Mann gemacht
Kanzler oder Scholz reist nach
Saudi-Arabien die Energiekrise zwingt
zum Pragmatismus fernab von
Menschenrechten so schaltet es
deutschland braucht Energie
ich besuche Mohammed das Saban der als
Berater des ölministers die saudische
Klimaschutz Delegation in Kyoto geleitet
hat ich möchte wissen ist Saudi-Arabien
ernsthafte in einem Energiewandel
interessiert
wir nennen das nicht Energiewandel
Energiewandel ist ein schlechtes Wort
für uns
das sage ich ihnen
Wandel bedeutet dass wir fossile
Brennstoffe verbannen werden und das ist
nicht die Realität man kann nicht
einfach sagen wir nehmen jetzt
Solarkraft oder Wind das ist Quatsch
und das hat der Krieg in der Ukraine
jetzt der ganzen Welt gezeigt inklusive
der europäischen unions
so I could dann könnte ich sie so
zusammenfassen bohren bis zum letzten
Tropfen Öl
bis zum letzten Tropfen
dann helfen sie mir zu verstehen warum
das Königreich in erneuerbare Energien
investiert einfach nur um die Kritiker
ruhig zu stellen nein nein wir müssen in
alle möglichen Energien investieren wir
müssen energieexporteur sein nicht nur
Öl und Gas
der weltgrößte Ölexporteur will künftig
weltweit größte wasserstoffproduzent
werden aber nicht um Klimaschutzziele zu
erreichen erzählt mir aus der Bahn
Wasserstoff werden wir vor allem nach
Europa exportieren weil es da eine große
Nachfrage gibt und das wird Geld
einbringen neben dem Öl
wir machen das ja nicht umsonst keine
Sorge wir werden euch das nicht umsonst
geben wir werden dafür viel Geld
bekommen und ihr werdet aus einer
Abhängigkeit in die nächste Abhängigkeit
geraten
also profitiert Saudi-Arabien
wenn Sie es haben wollen und es sich für
uns lohnt dann können wir natürlich
liefern das ist unser Prinzip aber wir
werden nichts liefern was unserem
wirtschaftlichen Nutzen entgegensteht
sorry wir werden alle Energiequellen
exportieren ob euch das gefällt oder
nicht wir haben eine neue internationale
Ordnung
es gibt nicht mehr nur Europa und die
USA es gibt China Russland und
Saudi-Arabien
wir sind sehr stark wir sind Teil der
G20 und wir werden weiterhin sehr aktiv
sein in dieser Gruppe
eine klare Ansage und politische
Machtdemonstration die zeigt mit wem wir
es zu tun haben
ich bereite mich auf eine besondere
Etappe meiner Reise vor ich will nach
Mekka fahren viele meiner
Familienmitglieder waren schon dort den
Hatch habe ich verpasst aber die
umrührer die kleine Pilgerfahrt ist
jederzeit möglich dazu brauche ich noch
die passende Ausstattung
kann ich alles zur Umra anziehen
jedes Modell und jede Farbe tragen es
gibt keine bestimmte Farbe frauen dürfen
die Farbe anziehen die sie tragen wollen
der Hutsch ist für Muslime verpflichtend
die umräder gegen freiwillig
[Musik]
das ist ein bisschen lang aber
ein bisschen lange ist gut
ich habe meine Mutter beten sehen mit
einem Ganzkörperschleier
mittlerweile macht sie das nicht mehr
aber sie hat über viele Jahre gemacht
insofern ist es glaube ich für mich ganz
natürlich ich habe meine Großmutter so
gesehen ich habe meine Tanten so gesehen
und wenn es für eine Zeremonie ist dann
ist es für mich okay aber ansonsten ist
für mich die Wahlfreiheit sehr wichtig
am nächsten Morgen bereite ich mich auf
meine Pilgerfahrt vor
[Musik]
ich bin ein bisschen aufgeregt weil
viele in meiner Familie das gemacht
haben also die ältere Generation für die
hat das eine ganz große Rolle gespielt
und ja natürlich denke ich daran dass
meine Großmutter mir immer Geschenke aus
meckern mitgebracht hat oder meine Tante
und an dem muss ich heute besonders
denken
mit dem Bus reise ich in die heilige
Städte meine nicht muslimischen Team ist
der Zutritt verboten ich bin gespannt
was mich dort erwartet
im ersten Teil meiner Reise habe ich
eine Region im Aufbruch erlebt vor allem
in Jitter
im nächsten Teil besuche ich das
märchenhafte Alula und Reise weiter nach
Kuwait und Dubai
[Musik]